le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
pendant sa jeunesse on passe une bonne
partie de son temps à l'école on
s'instruit on s'y fait des amis on
apprend la vie en société on prépare son
avenir mais parfois la vie nous oblige à
ne pas faire comme tout le monde un
divorce un drame familial certains
événements de la vie peuvent
compromettre la scolarité d'un enfant et
diminuer ses chances de réussir son
intégration sociale
alors comment concilier difficultés
familiales et réussite scolaire qu'elle
soutient peut-on espérer quand toutes
les portes se sont refermées
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
damien habitent dans les hauts de saint
denis c'est un garçon volontaire
agréable et posé
il y a quelques années ses parents ont
divorcé sa maman et ses deux petits
frères sont partis vivre en métropole
depuis il vit ici avec ses grands
parents
pour damien ce fut un événement très
difficile à vivre
conséquence directe sa vie scolaire a
été mise de côté fort heureusement il a
choisi de ne pas tomber dans la
délinquance
le ballet motivé par l' envie de réussir
sa vie damien passer des examens et des
tests pour trouver un emploi ou une
formation
mais il a cumulé les échecs en
particulier parce qu'il a beaucoup de
mal à s'exprimer par écrit
motivé mais bloqué par des portes
fermées damien découvert un dispositif
du conseil général qui accueille des
jeunes dont la principale qualité est
justement la motivation et l'envié de
s'en sortir plein kadimi dalons pour moi
c'est
quelque chose de streak
est quelque chose qui va emmener à qui
va aboutir à la fin avoir un métier
ma motivation c'est mes deux petits
frères pour augmenter les besoins
eux parce que
au parcours a été difficile je veux
montrer que mes deux petits fera que
même si c'est parfois difficile on peut
réussir
les grands parents de damien l'ont
accueilli après la séparation de ses
parents sa mamie fut pendant plusieurs
années assistante familiale pour des
enfants en perte de repères elle connaît
bien les cicatrices que peut laisser une
séparation dans une famille alors elle
et son mari soutiennent damien et
l'encouragent dans cette démarche et ses
ambitions ce car ils savent qu'une
grande partie de la reconstruction
provient de la volonté personnelle de
s'en sortir
malgré la séparation de ses parents
damien lui les lie nous écoute c'est
comme c'est comme mon enfant pas je peux
le lui dire ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il
faut pas fait il m'écoute c'est un
enfant agréable et vraiment il a du
respect pour nous
alors donc pour lui ça a été vraiment
une bonne chose puisque pour moi je lui
ai dit c'est le dernier virage lorsqu'il
a essayé un peu dans tout en lui
demander des tests il n'était pas à la
hauteur des tests et ça le bloquer en
dise que la halle académie des dalons il
n'y avait pas besoin de tests y avait
que des entretiens et lui il est plus à
pas répondre aux questions que d'écrire
on a hélas pas le niveau pour écrire et
tout donc la police a quand il a su
qu'il y avait pas de test écrit il était
vraiment très motivé et bien c'est
formidable c'est donner l'exemple à ses
deux petits frères à qui galère aussi en
métropole parce que bon ben ils veulent
retourner à la réunion mais bon
damien est très bien soutenus par ses
grands parents et grâce à l' académie
des dalons il va bénéficier aussi d'un
soutien extra familial avec des
professionnels qui vont l'aider à se
préparer pour entrer le mieux possible
dans la vie active
j'ai voulu lancer au conseil général un
programme ambition pour la jeunesse
réunionnaise et pour tous ceux qui ont
été déscolarisés trop tôt qui sont
sortis du système scolaire repose et
l'académie des dalons s'est proposé une
philosophie nouvelle pour qu'un jeune
puisse se saisir d de ses propres moyens
de ses potentialités pour au fond aller
vers un savoir être mais aussi un savoir
faire parce qu'il va apprendre à
réaliser des actions pour les
populations qui seront à proximité
justement de l' académie des dalons et
les jeunes ont été tellement nombreux à
répondre que nous voyons bien que ça
correspond à une dose
beaucoup de jeunes n'ont d'autre choix
que de surmonter les épreuves difficiles
de la vie certains tombent dans la
délinquance mais d'autres préfèrent s'en
sortir avec dignité le conseil général a
décidé de soutenir ces jeunes qui ont
momentanément perdu leurs repères mais
qui n'ont pas perdu les valeurs de la
vie en entrant à l' académie des dalons
certains jeunes font le choix de
remettre la chance de leur côté et
consacrent toute leur énergie à réussir
leur entrée dans la vie d'adulte
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais